Well, good morning again, church, uh, if you are new,
my name's John, one of the pastors here.
I would love to get to meet you.
We're grateful that you would be here.
Uh, if you have been here for many, many years,
we're also grateful that you're here.
So we love being together like this.
Uh, and what a Sunday it is.
As our kids and students move up a grade, they go
to the next stage of life in that they gear up for school.
Uh, I realize that some of you kids are in here
for the first time, and so I'm excited for that.
If you're a kindergartner, uh, we're thankful.
I know you can hang with me. I know we can focus in on that.
I, I, we talk about it up in kids all the time.
I, we, we expect that. We know we can.
Uh, and it's also partly
because we're gonna start a new sermon series today.
We're gonna start a new series in the Bible of preaching it
and seeing what God says to us.
And so that's
what we're kicking off today called He Shall Reign.
Uh, one of our elders made a dad joke.
Maybe we should have called it. It Shall Reign.
Uh, maybe that's what we saw today. No, he shall reign.
Uh, so I think we can look at First Samuel is
where we're gonna be as we look towards this series.
First Samuel, go ahead
and take your copy, God's word, turn there with me
in the Old Testament, not too far into the Bible.
You can find it amongst the history books there right
after Judges and Ruth Book of one Samuel.
You might put a bookmark there.
We'll be in there for a long time.
So just know that we're coming back to that over
and over again over the next few months.
It does mean we're heading back into the Old Testament,
back into narrative, which I'm super excited about studying
for myself, but also that we as a church get
to study this together.
But the question I've been asked already, why First Samuel,
why did we not pick any of the other ones?
Why this one? Well, first,
because David, the main character of First Samuel is one
of my favorite characters in the Bible.
So I just love his story and studying that, but also
because one of the most common titles given
to Jesus in the New Testament is Son of David.
So we need to understand what that even means.
Where's that coming from? Why is that so important?
We'll see that a lot here in one Samuel.
But before we get to one Samuel, we need to
answer some fundamental questions.
There's some foundational groundwork we need to lay
before we even study this book in itself.
So we're gonna start there.
Fundamental questions, things that relate to First Samuel,
but are generalized to more than just one Samuel.
So the first question is, what do we do
with narratives in the Bible?
What do we even do with narratives?
They're all over these stories that we see in the Bible.
What do we do with them? Well,
what are our options, first of all?
Well, we have seen some people consider them as kind
of like this mishmash of biographical sketches
and miracle stories
and just kind of tossed them together like a salad.
And that's what we have is the Old Testament.
Like, well, that's, that's not really the
right way to think about it.
In reality, what the Old Testament narratives do is they
give us a theological history of
how God related to his covenant people.
They, they talk about God's relationship
with his covenant people.
They are absolutely historical events,
but they're more than that.
They're more than just a, a social studies book
or a history textbook where it's factual information.
These were written down in the way God inspired them
to be written down for a theological purpose so
that we understand more about God
and we then know more about ourselves.
So when we look at these, we can't just think
that there's some kind of like lively engaging script
for a movie that you can see on Netflix, right?
We're not talking about any of that stuff.
They are good movies at times, but they're more than that.
They're intended to teach us about God,
and then again, in relation to that about ourselves,
so we can follow him more completely.
We can know him more fully, all of those things.
So we, we see narratives.
We don't just think they're cool stories.
They have a purpose. There's a second question
related to that though.
What do we then do with the characters?
What those characters in the plot lines
of those narratives, what do we do with them?
Again, what are our options?
Well, there is a trend out there
to take a character in a story and moralize them.
What that means is you take what that person did
or didn't do and say, well, we should do
or not do what they did or didn't do.
Right? And it's just strictly moralism based on
what they see or what they didn't.
Lemme just give you an example. Maybe you've heard this one.
Dare to be a Daniel, right?
You ever heard that one before as a kid growing up
and it's like, this is what you need to be.
You'd be like, Daniel. Well,
it's not always wrong.
I mean, we can emulate, but,
but it's not usually the primary point of the passage.
You understand that, right? It's not usually
what you should be focused on first,
it can be an application, but it's not first
and foremost the point of the narrative,
a point of that character.
And as I say that, just as a side note, if we're gonna dare
to be a Daniel, we better be prepared to do all
that Daniel actually did, right?
Not just the cool parts and the courageous parts,
but like everything all about his life and ministry.
So the characters, yes, they are important.
And often they're presented as positive
and negative models for us.
In fact, they're often contrasted, like we'll see with Saul
and David that there's positive things in the contrast
and negative things in the contrast.
So we see how they work together
to show us something about humanity.
But again, ultimately these are avenues
to show us more about who God is
and how he works through humanity.
What it teaches us about God first.
In fact, we can't forget
that God himself is actually a character in the narrative.
We're not just reading these stories
and seeing this person, that person,
God is not passive absent.
He's a major player in the narratives.
He speaks in dialogue with people.
He works within human related problems.
He delivers his people directly, not just
with an army he delivers.
So we can't miss him in the narrative
as we're reading the story,
we're seeing God is playing a major part here,
and that's what we want to know more about him
so we can love him more faithfully.
So that's two questions. There's a third one though.
And this one's maybe not as obvious,
but it's still as if not more important to the others.
As we're reading the Old Testament historical narratives,
the question is, what do we do with Jesus?
What do we do with Jesus?
In the Old Testament history, I know
that sounds provocative a little bit,
but just track with me here.
God, the Father, son, spirit triune God,
one God existed from
before time began, will exist forever and ever.
Eternity future never began, never ends.
But what we see, God, the Son taking on flesh happened
around the year zero, right?
So Jesus, per se,
we don't see show up till zero.
The problem here is the events in one Samuel take place
about a thousand years before that.
So yes, God always involved,
but Jesus the savior, redeemer, he didn't,
we didn't know till a thousand years later.
So what do we do?
How do, how do we read one Samuel
with Jesus still coming a thousand years later,
they were pre-Jesus, pre Messiah.
Because in the Gospels, think about it, in the gospels,
Jesus walking around, he's healing people teaching in the
acts and follows those letters.
In the New Testament, they're responding to Jesus.
So that's a little different.
But in first Samuel, the pre Messiah,
they were still looking forward.
We look back at it. So how do we read it?
Well, Jesus said something interesting in Luke 24, uh,
this is after his resurrection.
He's walking on the road to Emmaus with a couple
of his disciples and,
and listen to what Jesus, uh, he, he's referred to
as Luke's recording this about
what Jesus did in Luke 24, 27 says, beginning with Moses
and all the prophets, now Moses would be classified
as the first five books of the Old Testament.
And the prophets would be what continued
after that, speaking God's word, beginning with them,
he interpreted to them, to the disciples
in all the scriptures, the things concerning himself.
All the scriptures was the Old Testament to us.
That's all they had. So he began with the first part
and then interpreted through all of it, showing them,
Hey, this was about me.
This is about me. This is about me.
This is showing you who I'm gonna be.
This is showing you who I am.
That's what He's doing in Luke 24 27.
So here's what that means for us.
We're post even that we're further down the road.
And so we need to look back through the lens
of Christ into one Samuel.
We need to read one Samuel through the lens of the Messiah,
through the lens of Jesus.
Now, we'll read it in historical context, of course,
but it has to be read for us through that lens.
We've got to read it Christianly like we're not reading it
as they did 3000 years ago.
We're reading it now, knowing how it points us
to the eternal story of redemption.
God is weaving how it points us to
how God was making right, what went wrong in the garden,
how it shows us
what he was doing primarily through the story of David.
We'll see that. But ultimately,
how he was bringing about this Messiah
and how he continued the narrative, continued the story
to bring about the Messiah at
the right time in the right place.
We'll see types of Christ all through the narrative, right?
The the figure of what he will be like.
We'll see it in one Samuel.
We'll see how it shows us who God is
and who he is going to be for them in the Messiah.
It's starkly clear when we start to look
through those lenses so we could look at more questions,
foundational things, but I think that's good enough
to get us down the road as we go forward.
Now, what we need to do is set the context for
where we're at in this grand narrative of redemption.
Where are we even situated as we look at First Samuel,
where does it fit in?
Well, first Samuel Reeds like a,
a civics class in high school.
What it does is it records for later generations
of Israelites how they got their form of government.
What was good about it? What was bad about it?
Just like when you take social studies in elementary school
or you take government in high school or college and,
and it shows like, here's how the development happened
of our government here.
First Samuel is how that happened for Israel,
how they transitioned from judges to a monarchy.
What was good and bad about it.
But that didn't start there, right?
So there's a story before that.
So we've gotta find where we fit in.
Well, let's go back a lot further.
Remember how God chose Abraham
to be a nation set apart for his purposes, to have
many sons and daughters that would bless all nations
through him, a distinct nation that would then come
through his promised son, Isaac,
who then had a son named Jacob who received the same promise
that Abraham received before him.
Well, then if you recall, one
of Jacob's sons was named Joseph, whose brothers hated him
and sold him into slavery in Egypt.
But that was God's plan
because when Joseph was in Egypt, he was risen to power.
And when he was in power, was able to save many nations
because of what he had done.
Well, what happened as part of that was Jacob
and his family are brought to Egypt with Joseph.
They're protected, and they eventually grow to this
huge nation within Egypt.
Well, a Pharaoh comes along later that doesn't know Joseph,
and he sees how big this nation is inside his own borders,
and he gets a little afraid.
And so he says, you're all my slaves now.
And he enslaves the people of Israel, makes them
captive in that.
But God still was working with that distinct nation,
and he delivers his people out of slavery
through the plagues, through the Red Sea,
and through 40 years of rebellious,
wandering through the wilderness.
He brings them by Moses' leadership to the edge
of the Promised Land.
That's effectively Genesis through Deuteronomy,
the first five books of the Bible.
That's the story. Well,
the next book of the Bible is called Joshua.
Joshua was the one who followed Moses in
leadership of God's people.
And he led them into the promised land where they were able
to drive out their enemies and begin to settle in the land.
But they weren't fully there yet.
Because what comes next is judges.
Judges is what God put in place to lead
and protect his people.
Even though it's a loosely Confederated tribes of 12
in one place with one religion, there was this need
to be protected and they were mostly safe.
And what that does is that brings us to one Samuel.
And so we're gonna put a little chart on the screen,
and this is gonna be, this is where we're at,
the transition period.
You might wanna take a picture of that.
We're gonna kind of walk through
it through the next couple months.
That's what we can see is this process God has brought us to
of judges, protecting.
They're in the land, they're somewhat safe,
they're loosely connected, but there's no central authority.
And what happens in one Samuel is this shift to a monarchy.
To a kingship. That's what you see here.
The main characters are involved.
You see kind of the pathway, how they overlapped.
You see Saul and David,
who are the two primary players in all of this, but,
but this is the historical reality, the factual information
of what happens in one Samuel as a result
of God's story, getting them here.
But you look at that, and it's not enough though,
because yes, that's the facts, that's the history of this.
But those narratives are not only, I said this
before, they're not only history.
There's a theological purpose
to teach us something about God first
and about ourselves in relation to that.
So we'll get, we got the history, we got the context,
but now what we need to see is the themes we'll see
throughout First Samuel,
what will God teach us?
What he will he remind us of throughout this book?
It's exciting, it's narrative.
And some of the favorite stories we know
and love are in First Samuel, but,
but what do we do with it?
What is, what's God trying to teach us?
Well, there's, I'm just gonna give six today.
There's probably way more, but,
but we wanna keep our eyes open for him as we work
through the next few weeks.
First, the words
of God is a major theme in First Samuel, the words of God.
If you remember I said, a thousand years
before Jesus shows up,
that means there was no finalized canon of scripture.
We don't, uh, we we have this as a result of the process.
The early church went through to canonize the scriptures.
Well, they didn't have that a thousand years before Jesus.
So prophets were essential back then.
Prophets were the very mouthpieces of God.
They were speaking God's word to the people of God.
And over and over in one Samuel will see how important words
are, whether God spoke himself
or whether he was using his words through people.
God was blessing. God was cursing.
God was bringing about His will through words.
Often we'll see it again.
He's a primary player. He's not absent. He's involved.
He's directing in many ways with His word.
And along with that, we'll see the holiness of God.
We see his words are important and we'll see.
The holiness of God is very important.
In one Samuel, there's actually a couple pretty shocking
scenes in one Samuel
where God vindicates his name pretty forcefully.
Like we'll watch how he deals with religious leaders who
mock him and, and handle his name with irreverence.
We'll see how he handles false gods and idols.
In fact, one of my favorite stories in scripture is in one
Samuel five where there was this God that was being set up,
name was Dagon.
Now Dagon was a god of fertility.
And they had this wooden, or, or,
or a stone image of Dagon in a temple
that they would go to worship.
And these were nations right around Israel.
Well, we'll see this arc of the covenant, the presence
of God, uh, symbol in e in Israel was, was taken
and it was put in front of Dagon
as kind of like, look, we won.
Well, the next morning they come in the temple
and that massive stone
or wood idol was flat on his face
right in front of the Ark of the Covenant.
So they're like, okay,
there must have been an earthquake or something.
I dunno what they were thinking. But then the,
so they set him back up.
They notice, they set the God back up
the next morning they come in, not only is he faced down,
his head's cut off and his arms are cut off.
Who did that? God did.
God was vindicating his holiness saying, you don't mess
with me and no God can stand against me.
That's just a picture of what we're going to be faced with
as we walk through one Samuel God vindicating his holiness,
which means we will be confronted
in the same way with that question.
Who can stand before this?
Holy God, who can stand
and, and we know apart from Christ, we are face down.
We have no reason to stand before God. He is holy.
We're not apart from Christ intervention. We will be undone.
So we'll see the holiness of God here, which leads
to the third theme very closely related,
the depravity of humankind.
This is in one Samuel, the depravity of humankind.
What we see it over
and over again, how wicked people can get.
And we typically, I I've been wrestling
with this a little myself in the last few weeks.
We typically have a much higher view
of ourselves than we ought to, right?
We, we tend to view ourselves really highly.
And I think it shows up often when we read about characters
in the Bible who sin in big ways.
Like we'll read stuff in one Samuel
or elsewhere in the Bible,
and we'll, we'll read what they did.
And we're like, how in the world could you ever do that?
Maybe I'm the only one who says this,
but like, do you not see?
Did, did you not know what was about to come?
And we, we think there's no way I could have ever done that.
Ooh, let's be careful with that.
That's a pretty arrogant statement, isn't it?
How deceived we are.
Now, it is true that in Christ, if you are in Christ,
you don't have to sin like that.
But I want you to hear what God inspired the Apostle Paul
to write in one Corinthians 10,
as he was thinking about stories like we're about
to read in one Samuel, those stories of utter failure
and mess in people's lives.
Listen to this. Now, these things took place as examples
for us that we might not desire.
Evil as they did, do not be idolaters as some of them were.
As it is written, the people sat down to eat and drink
and rose up to play, meaning they were
cherishing those things more than God.
We must not indulge in sexual immorality as some
of them did, and 23,000 died in a single day.
We must not put Christ to the test as some of them did
and we're destroyed by serpents
nor grumble as some of them did,
and we're destroyed by the destroyer.
Now, these things happen to them as an example,
but they were written down for our instruction
on whom the end of the ages has come.
Now listen to this. Check out verse 12.
Therefore, let anyone who thinks that he stands
take heed lest he fall.
Meaning don't be arrogant.
Be warned by those stories.
No, I I could never do that. No, no, no.
Be warned that there are consequences to sin.
There's consequences to rebellion that we, we know the grace
of God covers us, but
that doesn't give us license to do whatever we want.
We know that this causes this. You reap what you sow.
There's consequence to it.
So instead of just saying, well, the grace of God covers me,
how about we just avoid it to begin with
and not have to go through the pain and sorrow?
That's what these stories are meant to show us.
It's like, well, I don't wanna do what that guy did.
I see the consequence. I wanna avoid that.
We'll see the depravity of humankind
and the consequence to it here.
Here's the next theme we're gonna see in one Samuel,
it's the responsibilities of leaders.
Again, with the kingship idea,
the responsibilities of leaders.
Both the qualifications of leaders,
but also what they are to do.
We'll see good leaders, we'll see bad leaders.
We will see God's standard for leaders.
And we'll see what happens when people pick leaders based on
some other standard than what God said.
It doesn't go well,
and it's gonna be instructive for us who are leaders.
It'll be instructive to those who want to be leaders.
But it's gonna be instructive for all of us
because we all have influence on other people
and we're called to lead them, whether it's as parents
or coworkers or bosses or fellow students.
It's leadership. This is what we are to do.
Yet in the end, it will point us back
to Christ who's our ultimate leader.
The only perfect one that we can follow.
That was number four. Here's the fifth,
the sovereignty of God.
I mean, we could put this as a theme
for everything of course in the Bible.
But this one clearly shows up here the sovereignty of God,
that God is fully in control.
Over and over in one Samuel, we'll see
that God ordered events and circumstances for his purpose.
He got people where they needed
to be when they needed to be there.
He told them what they needed to hear,
had them overhear something they needed to overhear,
and he protected who he needed to protect.
He put them where they needed to be so they could be safe.
All of that. God is super intending this whole thing.
In fact, you see God work even when there
seems like there's no way out.
There's worldly ways.
It's nothing ever possible to get outta this.
And God says, no, no, no, that's not a problem for me.
I got this. Let me show you
my glory as I do it.
He's always at work. In fact, he's weaving this story.
We'll watch it happen in one Samuel,
how God weaves this redemption story all throughout
to eventually point us to that Son of David Messiah.
Well, here's the sixth one.
And really I think it, it might be the primary
theme of the book.
They're all important of course.
But this one is number one, the kingship
of God in one Samuel,
the kingship of God.
They're all related, of course, but this one matters
because of the plot line of the book.
Like I said earlier, the central focus is the
monarchy of of Israel.
How they moved from judges to kings, from judges
to one nation under a king.
Now, this is the narrative. Here's the problem with that.
The problem is that that's not the way God
ever wanted it to be.
In fact, it says explicitly, their desire for a king was
because they wanted
to be like all the other nations around them.
Now, God graciously works through this.
He sets up a model king in David.
He points us to the son of David who's gonna
come reign perfectly.
He does that in spite of this.
But remember when God called Israel,
when he redeemed them out of slavery,
he said, you are my own.
What did he say it was for? So they would be distinct.
A holy nation is what he called them.
A people who would point others towards Yahweh.
They would show that God's presence is with them.
They would show that he's promised a redeemer.
That's what he wanted them to be as Israel.
They were not to be like other nations around them.
They already had a king, and his name was Lord God Almighty.
You don't need anybody else. You don't need to be like them.
I am your king, and I want you to be distinct.
You see how instructive this is for us today.
Like do you see how relevant
that very word is for us
even in the age of Christ?
I mean, just listen to how one Peter two verses nine
and 10 says this, but you
Christians, you are a chosen race,
a royal priesthood, a holy nation, a people
for his own possession so
that you may proclaim the excellencies of him
who called you out of darkness into his marvelous light once
you were not a people, but now you are God's people.
Once you had not received mercy,
but now you have received mercy, right?
You see that it's the same language
that he used about Israel back then.
It's the same desire he had that by redemption,
we are now God's people.
We are God's people. His holy nation, meaning we are his.
He is our king.
Continue on verse 11, beloved, I urge you as sojourners
and exiles to abstain from the passions of the flesh,
which wage war against your soul.
Keep your conduct among the Gentiles honorable so
that when they speak against you as evil doers,
they may see your good deeds
and glorify God on the day of visitation.
Again, the same purpose.
He wants us to be distinct, to point
to God's presence with us, to point to his redeemer for us.
That's why he's made us a holy nation.
And did you see the words in there, sojourners and exiles?
Peter was writing to people who were in exile.
But there's other scriptures you tie with that,
that we are sojourners and exiles as believers.
Meaning we are not home here.
This is not home. This is a temporary dwelling place.
Until we do get home, someday, we're living somewhere else
for now until we finally get home.
What that means is that we are not of this worldly kingdom,
Which means we shouldn't look for a king here
to bring in some kingdom version here.
Why? 'cause we already have a king. We already have a king.
We're a holy nation with a king
who reigns over us forever and ever and ever.
That's our hope.
He installs kings and leaders as he sees fit. Absolutely.
Are they subject to his commands? Absolutely.
But it's him who's going to reign forever
and ever over his kingdom.
So I know we agree with that in our heads,
but the challenge is that we keep him there in our hearts.
That that throne is occupied by him alone. Nothing else.
No one else. No hope other than him.
Are we keeping him there? That'll be a question
as we walk through one.
Samuel, what is taking that throne away
from the one who rightly sits on it?
Israel's demand for a king was a rejection of God.
May it never be. So for us as families, as individuals,
as a church, may it never be so for us, even
to any extent that we say, no,
my way's better God not yours.
So I want you to just bow your head for a second,
to invite you to something, to just focus.
Close our head, close, close our eyes and bow our heads.
And we look at, look at what God wants
to show to us in this.
So I would just invite you now to consider
your need for God, your need
for a king.
How So often we run to these other
little K kings looking
for answers, looking for hope
and life instead of realizing the king of kings
and Lord of Lords is already on that throne.
And we can trust it. We can be satisfied in.
And so that's the question today,
does he rule in your life?
Have you said, God, I'm yours.
Everything is yours. You are my king.
You are my Lord. You are the one
who calls the shots, directs traffic.
You are everything
and you are my savior.
And you recognize you need salvation because of your sin
and your rebellion against God.
And you say, God, I need you to save me from your wrath.
It's the only way through that son of David, Jesus Christ,
who has done it all for you.
That's the only way.
But it's not one or the other. It's king and Savior.
That's how he comes.
So just reflect for a second, consider for a moment how,
how that plays out day to day for you
and run to him in that.